Selena Gomez calls the weekend her best
friend I just feel really blessed in the
September issue of InStyle magazine the
25 year old pop star opens up about
canceling her revival tour in 2016 and
going away for 90 days to focus on
herself quote it was the best thing that
I ever could have done I learned a lot
I'm in a really really healthy place
I'm just so confident and comfortable
and I feel free more than I've ever felt
in my whole life and she has a new
outlook on love it's a great feeling
quote I don't depend on one area of my
life to make me happy it's really
important for me to love and nourish my
friends and family and to make sure that
I never get influenced by a guy the
fetish singer gets candid about her
relationship with the weekend and how
it's different than her past boyfriends
you want someone to add to your life not
to complete you I'm lucky because he's
more of a bestfriend than anything else
Selena was all smiles in April telling
et she's feeling good these days you
know my personal life and my family
my friends I'm just a really happy place
I'm good